let's talk about convenience when you're
talking about convenience about having a
car
you're self-reliant it's on you you come
and go as you please you do what you
want to do you don't got to get in a car
with anybody else
who's this driver i'm not so sure can i
trust them can i not trust them
it's on you okay cool no big deal the
one catch with that is
don't text and drive you got that okay
now talking about convenience with the
lift or uber you're dependent
on the driver it's not on you you can't
come and go as you please you got to
wait for them to pick you up
you're driving with a stranger do you
know them do you not know them i don't
know can you trust them you're in the
back seat
who knows some people are creeped out by
these things some people i don't give a
it's all good
here's the catch though you can text and
drive and work while you're driving
so that is some sort of convenience
while someone else is driving moving
right along
let's talk about worst case scenario
this is a
big thing so pay attention now big thing
this is the last thing you want with
your car you get a flat tire you're on
the side of a road you're waiting on
aaa to come fix a tire do you know how
to change a tire all of a sudden you're
dealing with maybe an accident god
forbid someone backed into you
your car's in the shop you're dealing
with that crap god forbid
worst case scenario you'll get a dui
that might cost you five
ten thousand dollars to deal with the
dui that is a nightmare situation
you would likely want to avoid okay
understand that okay so now what's worst
case scenario with a lifter uber well
maybe the driver cancels they get lost
you go the wrong route you charge a
little bit extra you got to get a refund
that's a worst case scenario
maybe you're wasted you puke in the car
you got to pay 200 bucks
because you puked in someone's car
that's worst case scenario i don't know
about you but
worst case scenario over here is a lot
worse than this worst case scenario
that's just my opinion i don't know what
do you think
now let's talk about depreciation this
is a huge
factor when you have a car depreciation
i don't know if you know this but a car
is a depreciating asset let me say that
again a car
is a depreciating asset the average cost
of a car thirty thousand dollars that's
for a new car
after the first year it depreciates 30
and then it depreciates 15 year after
year after year
you bought a car for 30 grand next thing
you know it's five years later and it's
only worth
12 grand that's how depreciation works
now how much is depreciation
on your lift or uber well it's n a zero
zero depreciation because it's not your
car all good
last but not least let's talk about
total cost we've done the math we've run
the numbers
here's the total cost to having a car on
average per year
so the average cost of a car to own a
car total
all the way down 8 500 per year okay
so if you're doing basic math here
you're talking you're spending between
400 and 500 dollars between a new car
used car
whatever so if you do the math on that
that only comes out to about four or
five grand
but a car costs you 8 500 bucks a year
well we just did the math
all these things add up moving right
along let's talk about the total cost
of an uber or lyft well it comes out to
about four thousand dollars a year
that's if
you're taking a car three to four trips
a week that's just basic math right
there
so the total cost favors lyft
or uber versus having a car but the
question
is what should you do